warum sagt denn keiner dass
offensichtlich ist die suite des kaisers
neue kleider keiner sagt dass der kaiser
nackt ist niemand sagt außer mir ein
schlechtes wort über dieses buch ich
habe den eindruck du bist bei debis
besonders streng an das stimmt überhaupt
nicht echt nein das stimmt nicht
es stimmt überhaupt nicht stimmt nicht
nur das stimmt so was von überhaupt
nicht das ist ja glaub ich etwas worüber
wir tatsächlich am meisten streiten dass
ich gerne mir anschaue was so nachkommt
in der deutschsprachigen literatur und
duda wahnsinnig streng immer bist und
ich einfach eine größere offenheit wie
siehst du das wieder ausdrücke aber
bewusst dass wieder so aus als sei ich
das absolute monster und wo die gute fee
möchte gerne konkret auf dieses buch so
wie sie kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht
zusammen das erstlingswerk hier ist noch
alles möglich dass titel ist das beste
ein buch wenn du mich fragst molinari
es gibt nicht eine einzige erinnern dass
werte metapher in diesem ganzen buch es
gibt nicht eine einzige originelle
personen zuschreibung in diesem ganzen
buch es gibt nicht einen einzigen
bleiben den vergleich in diesem ganzen
minuten sie findet überraschende bilder
für viele themen die unsere gesellschaft
heutzutage auch gehen also warum sollte
man das lesen es ist sehr schön
geschrieben es ist nicht manieriert es
erzählt einfach eine geschichte was
sonst in unseren haften albernen 100
lagen aber schon diese bringt
verschiedene ebenen der erzählung das
ist eigentlich wunderbar das ist
eingrenzung der himmel ist entgrenzt es
hat alles was mit grenzen zu tun welche
einsicht wirklich transport findet die
einsicht dass wir uns gedanken darüber
machen sollten wer gehört zu unserer
gesellschaft dazu und wen schließen wir
aus ich möchte die behauptung wagen und
sagen dieses buch ist gar nicht für
leser geschrieben das ist genau das was
ich literaturbetriebs prosa nenne und es
funktioniert hervorragend und es dient
der weltbild bestätigung und
selbstversicherung des literaturbetriebs
ich finde das eine sehr viel
versprechende autorin ich möchte auch
mal darauf hinweisen dass ich durchaus
auch ein debüt super finden kann
das hier ist es die in einer britischen
autorin ich wusste überhaupt nichts über
diese frau und dann hat das buch aus
sich selbst heraus mich in seinen bann
gezogen weil es ein ganz
faszinierendes geschildert das leben
einer person ist wenn ich nichts gewusst
hätte hätte ich nie gedacht das ist ein
debüt ist also liebe leute so vertraut
nicht zu sehr auf die literaturkritik
nur uns vertraut nur uns und im zweifel
wenn wir nicht einer meinung sind
vertrauen sie mir
[Musik]